hey what's happening this jeep rico
check me out on a bootleg calf podcast
enterprise click baby
all right man bullet cat podcast special
guest the guy jeep rico is in here man
welcome what's happening man we're
trying to do this for a while man i'm
glad to finally get you up here bro yeah
it was a rough morning my [ __ ] car
got towed and yeah we're here oh my
[ __ ] my other car wouldn't start this
i was going to drive my low key i should
say if it wouldn't start but was it old
school nah it's it's a 2020. oh okay i
hadn't drove it in like eight months and
then i drove it the other day
and i had to get it jumping in this
morning it didn't start again i'm like
[ __ ] well look you're here man uh
welcome and uh first of all you've had
an interesting journey in this music
[ __ ] right so like
originally i remember you know when you
were starting to buzz you tapped in with
fuzz over at priority yeah yeah yeah the
priority thing didn't work out at all
yeah i'm not saying it didn't work out
priority build day [ __ ] it like
went left right but it helped me a lot
right like they did good with you but i
just think like obviously priority
didn't last yeah priority didn't that
[ __ ] was around for like maybe a year
right right right then you end up with
rock nation yeah um
which would you know i feel like roc
nation is an interesting company because
it's so great at so many things but i'm
not sure
the label side
fits
la artist
right right how was your experience
because it was about two years you were
there yeah two years how was the two
years over over there i mean
the way i look at it like
you know outside of the label because
the label was it was musical chairs like
they was trying to figure out they got
they went through so many employees
i remember every like it felt like every
nine months there was like everyone at
roc nation got fired and they hired a
bunch it was it was it was crazy yeah
sooner than that i went to a few
different project managers and so they
was trying to figure that out but
like my whole thing like i learned so
much being able to be over there because
i get to i get to talk to sit in the
office with jay brown and
i get to sit with emery like dave like
every day with emery though right cause
every more i just talked to him this
morning
um
and that's like that's a billion dollar
circle how often do you get to hang
around a billion dollar circle so i'm
like a fly on the wall soaking up game
and um
like that part of the situation was
priceless
so so you know i don't
it was great for me for you um
getting off rock nation and deciding to
go with empire going to independent
route
um
what was the deciding point for you and
and were you like did you ask to get off
the label like how did that happen yeah
so i mean naturally i'm an independent
dude you know what i'm saying that's how
you got here i don't like
like
having to basically ask for permission
to do anything like you know what i mean
because
like this is this is art and it's no
specific way that you do [ __ ] when you
get with a label you stuck in this
in this box uh i call it the chain of
command that you got to go through this
and then they gotta understand your idea
and then you gotta go through this
there's a lot it's it's too much you
know what i'm saying so i never really
wanted to sign
a record deal in the first place you
know what i mean so
you know as time went on it was just you
know time for me to jet
i asked to go and they real true players
you know what i'm saying they let me go
like i was out i requested to go
and i was out in
a week you know what i mean
yeah i think like the type of [ __ ] you
make bro is like it's like and
you being independent
makes the most sense exactly you
stacking up your catalog you just kind
of keep building on what you have that
core following that you have you know
what i'm saying like yeah how is it how
has it like you know
the last you i feel like well it's been
about what nine months since you've been
on empire uh a year yeah about nine
about nine months nine months yeah yeah
so how has that been uh october 10
months it's crazy it's october 10 months
so we going on 10 months yeah how's it
been man because like obviously i feel
like the music output has been high and
man awesome bro like i could see
everything and
you know the thing with empire that's
dope like they get you the rope you know
what i'm saying you could either hang
yourself with it or climb up it you know
i mean some real [ __ ] and it's like
you know when you sign with a major
label right it go like this you get your
what i should have did when i signed
with the major i should have took my
advance instead of going to do my [ __ ]
and shaw you know i love cars and [ __ ]
instead of doing that i should have
spent all that money
on
the music and [ __ ] myself and just got
the money back from them later yeah
because you had to use that budget and
then you had budget you got to pay that
back right on top of the events and so i
should have just took the advance and
jump started myself but
see this the thing between indies and
majors well empire i don't know all
indies but like empire and then i had a
situation with priority this the thing
like when you sign with a major they
give you your advance but
you got to have some [ __ ] going or you
got to have the entire office convinced
for your budget to even open up you know
what i'm saying so you got to jump
through loops and do a gang of [ __ ] to
even get going in the first place even
after you sign after you did all the
work and sign for them to approve video
budgets and all of this [ __ ] gotta make
sense it's so much [ __ ] so much [ __ ]
red tape that you gotta cut through now
with empire
whatever you [ __ ] sign whatever your
budget is is right there
you could go get straight to it
immediately you ain't got to waste no
time now if you [ __ ] it off that's
honestly that's on you now if you do
your thing
then i mean naturally if you're a
businessman you're going to do your
thing so i mean that's the that's the
great part about empire like they just
let you go well speak to that like
because i do think a lot of mistakes
that get made is what you just said
right you got an advance from a major
and maybe you didn't spend it in the
smartest way and i went splurging
[Laughter]
and a lot of people don't realize like
you know you get that advance and
your music has to make that much money
back
times whatever your terms are otherwise
the conversations get dry and also other
changes also otherwise you're um
you're not going to see any money off
your music
you know what i mean like that's your
big nut and you got to kind of make that
[ __ ] stretch you know what i'm saying so
what was like
like if if you're if you're you know
young independent artist watching this
what would be some advice you'd give
them as far as you know taking the
advance or
i mean i would say like with the advance
invest it like straight back in yourself
pay some bills but invest it straight
back into the business because at the
end of the day if the music not going
and you ain't got nothing cracking in
the people face
and marketing and going like what that
advance mean like you got a chain and
some money and so you know it means zero
you know what i'm saying so
i would say like from my personal
experience i didn't do it i wish i would
have did it like with that specific play
you know i'm saying it'd probably be a
different situation right now
take the advance and invest it in
yourself marketing and promo um
videos
um digital campaigns like spend it on
that you know what i mean and make the
label open up your budget or you know
well it's also crazy too because like
once you're on a major label it seems as
if things get everything gets more
expensive
everything is more like message you go
into the studio
like as an indie 500 as an independent
artist you go to the studio i mean you
can book my studio for 60 bucks an hour
with an engineer right they're gonna put
you at paramount whatever and then
you'll see the bill on your
and you're like wait a minute how wait
what yeah yeah
it's like every even the video it's like
yo like like like i was saying like bro
you got here doing doing doing you
exactly you know what i'm saying you got
your own video people you got i mean
this is your city you know what i'm
saying so i think a lot of people don't
realize like pay attention to the little
details when they do something like hey
man not every studio session needs to
cost definitely 300 an hour because
before you know it you'll be like uh
they'll send you or you'll audit the
books or ask how much you spent and
they'd be like yeah 1.5 million and
you'd be like what damn where the [ __ ]
where about
that yeah is that how much you spent uh
i spend some money you spend some money
i'm assuming so let me because like did
you recoup at roc nation nah not all the
way did they
so but they were cool with just kind of
saying you know what so it's basically
like uh they got your catalog that you
dropped over there yeah my arm a few
dollars not a lot though but you could
drop freely
now without having to yeah i could do
whatever i want all right man solid on
their part yeah
nah they like that's like the thing
about like roc nation like i never have
anything bad to say like it's dope
people over here like awesome people for
sure you know what i mean it's just um
i feel like i just didn't have my thing
all the way figured out and you know
like me personally when i got something
figured out i'm aggressively moving in
that direction
so it was kind of like i was in limbo
trying to
i was like a fish out of water in
certain situations you know what i mean
and um but like everybody over there
great omar sherry
like i said emery is my guy
yeah so
that emery's emory i hope one day uh i
could interview emery and talk about his
story because his story is crazy he's
the yeah
if you think about like
i mean i guess maybe just the perception
of what happened like he kind of took it
on the chin for hope you know what i'm
saying so hope could stay out and do his
thing
and then he gets out and he's running
rock n it's it's so fired yeah shout out
to emery um so you've also been like
doing a lot just on the entrepreneur
[ __ ] like you launched your the
obviously you got this the shirt on yeah
blue t-shirts these are blue t-shirts
becoming a staple yes this is like the
best [ __ ] that i [ __ ] created bro i
didn't expect it to do
what it's been doing but uh man this
[ __ ] is crazy yeah for people i mean
obviously the concept is amazing yeah
because you know for people who don't
know your affiliations they can google
them we're not going to talk about them
officially but
it's a white shirt with red lettering
but it says this is a blue t-shirt
yeah
yeah so i mean um
when i when i started it i was sitting
in the back of one of my shops and [ __ ]
and i'm like man i want to start
something new because the last [ __ ] that
i had was the way i branded it it was so
limited to my hood at this point
that [ __ ] is just a click in my hood at
this point you know i'm saying so it's
like
man what can i do universal to you know
really get the bag and really get
through to people without having to
explain
a long [ __ ] on what this is right
like this is self-explanatory like
however you take it you know i'm saying
at the end of the day is perception but
uh
like you know so many people uh
[ __ ] with it like you know i'm saying
like
oh white guys um young kids like old
ladies young
everybody like you know uh gravitates to
the to the blue t-shirt [ __ ] and when i
dropped it
it went so crazy
like i never had sales like that on
anything you know what i'm saying that
[ __ ] was crazy no it's it's dope because
i mean you've got the tattoos which is
fire
um troll blow i just think it's simple
it's simple and it's like clean as [ __ ]
to wear and like you said like
you know if someone gets a subway out
sweater that's a lot to explain
yeah you know you know what i'm saying
exactly like this is just something
where it's like there's probably kids in
oklahoma rocking that shirt right now or
some [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
that's definitely yeah we got a we got a
nice little audience out there um
something i feel like you've done a good
job of doing in la is working with a
wide spectrum of
artists here and i want to say you were
kind of like the class before
um the ruchies and the chikes and those
guys like you were active before them in
the music game but i kind of feel like
you are a part of that initial class
that was like
not as divided as we've seen la be in
the past
yeah definitely and
with la hip hop there's always politics
no matter what happens right yeah for
sure and
you know we've seen street politics
equal artists that want to work with
each other not working with each other
in the past for sure you know what i
mean like i remember talking to q about
like why you never work with nipsey it's
obvious right yeah um but at the same
time like i feel like the new
generation of los angeles artists
to a higher extent than i've ever seen
at least
have
done a great job of either putting that
stuff to the side and working together
or just automatically just tapping in
with each other now obviously there's
always going to be some drama you know
what i'm saying but what is it about la
right now that you feel like
has a
a real united feel to it um
you know naturally this is the gang city
the gang culture so
like you said it's uh
you know people that i run with might
not get along with you know people that
i want to work with around with but
what's going on right now is like
a lot of the artists that's up and
coming not really
gang affiliated
to a certain extent you know what i mean
right a lot of people didn't they didn't
grow up gang banging or don't really
have like
the super gang bangers around in the mix
and it's it's it's just a lot more
players a lot more people about their
money
you know i'm seeing in the [ __ ] and i
think it's dope you know what i'm saying
um
i actually was tripping one day when i
when i noticed what was going on i'm
like [ __ ] everybody working together and
there's no problems you know what i'm
saying which is like
never happened out here hopefully it'll
keep going but hopefully it keeps going
um
it's just like you know um
a lot of people were able to look past
it and then a lot of people like not
wrapped up in the gang [ __ ] so deep that
you know they letting that [ __ ] hinder
whatever happened i wish i was that good
you know what i'm saying i'm like
i'm tied into this [ __ ] like certain
people i'm never gonna work with like
and they might be cool or whatnot but
it's just like
just like where i come from and the [ __ ]
that i believe in it's like
you know it is or i just got to just
know that a person is genuine you know
what i'm saying because i don't want to
be doing music with somebody and then
later on they cool with me but they own
some [ __ ] this in my hood or something
like you know so i think that's what
stopped a lot of [ __ ] previously and
what's bringing [ __ ] together is
like [ __ ] not really like
yeah like you'll talk to like like kids
and they'll be like yo like i really
didn't grow up that way my uncles were
or you know i grew up in that area but
like i wasn't active so it's a lot
easier for me to reach across the aisle
and work with you know exactly and
that's dope you know i'm saying because
a lot of you know like over the years a
lot of people didn't a lot of people
from the previous time didn't grow up
gang banging but you know for that image
and that certain thing and the
surrounding people
like they let that [ __ ] hinder [ __ ] like
you know it's a lot of it's i can't
really name too many artists from los
angeles right like in the last even in
the last 10 years that actually really
grew up gang banging you know i'm saying
like or in the mix you know what i'm
saying but you know [ __ ] is
affiliated and
you know the image and the people around
[ __ ] [ __ ] up i mean yeah it doesn't hurt
record sales for people to believe
you're a gang member oh that [ __ ] is
great especially for l.a artists like
that's what this [ __ ] is about like
yeah just the land of the gang bang here
in chicago you know what i'm saying yeah
it's kind of it's kind of you know
also that's unfortunate because you know
like you said like i'm sure there's a
lot of artists a lot of people who got
wrapped up in some [ __ ] they never need
to get wrapped up into just for yeah
just for the cloud or the image you know
what i'm saying it's like
it you know it is with it i was talking
to um whack a couple of weeks ago
and he was like definitively like you
know
i could never in good faith tell anybody
to get involved in gang [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying i've been there i i
took those lumps
to be in a position where i could tell
people that's not the way to go like i'm
assuming you kind of feel similar uh my
whole thing with the you know how i look
at it is
uh because the gang is a community
first of all who do we just talk to that
said gangbanging wasn't necessarily a
bad or being in a gang rather
necessarily isn't a bad thing
yeah d smoke just said
it's definitely not and it doesn't start
as that right it's definitely not
because the the gang is naturally the
community you know what i'm saying and
um
you know everybody from the gang since
the beginning of time is not a [ __ ]
killer you know what i'm saying or even
not people that commit crimes like i got
big homies that
my whole entire life knowing them they
had jobs and they was family man
but you know they was a part of the
community and they showed they support
which is necessary
yummy and helping like younger homies
find their way you know what i'm saying
now
if
if everybody from the area just decided
to man [ __ ] this [ __ ] i ain't talking to
nobody i ain't dealing with where does
that leave the people that come next you
know what i'm saying it it
so it's like a real thin line but i
definitely wouldn't tell nobody to go
kill nobody or go do no [ __ ] like that
or commit no crimes i would say like all
right if that's where you from
you know represent where you're from but
you don't have to be a [ __ ] gang
banger you could be a doctor a lawyer a
fireman a [ __ ] cop if you want to you
know i'm saying but
you know i wouldn't just say uh
like [ __ ] the hood like that you know
what i'm saying i would say like
crips and bloods originally started as
like community organizations right like
you know like you said like i mean you
know that's what
that's one way to look at it you know
what i'm saying but like
when you really think about it like it
was like just a gang of young dudes 15
14 16 like doing knucklehead [ __ ] in the
community you know what i mean
i mean it didn't start off as some
killing [ __ ] like we killing each other
but you know it was definitely like
always at odds with some type of [ __ ]
that's how [ __ ] really started you know
i mean like
it get deep i don't even want to go into
that but hey so let me ask you this
because this is something i had to learn
head had to teach me this when i first
moved to la
um
not you what what hats are okay to wear
anywhere in la i know there's only a few
la hat black
head's always like black la hat
it's the only one
but you know like a black la hat that's
really it
the the diamondbacks like that right
there uh tampa bay tv uh santana black
yeah i mean
20 bloods you know what i mean yeah
yeah are the arizona diamondbacks
uh avalon anthony's park uh
you know
a black la hat is the safe safe bet yeah
black la hat is probably as neutral as
it get yeah i mean
at least if you're gonna i'm in the
valley i haven't had any issues in the
valley
oh yeah the valley hey you know what's
dope about the valley so when i got out
of i got out of prison and [ __ ] in 2014
20 the end of 2013.
um
[Music]
i was living in a studio on 108 from
broadway
and um
somebody have got a hold of my social
and [ __ ] while i was in jail and [ __ ]
my credit running your show nobody would
rent me no apartment like my credit was
[ __ ] up so i finally got a spot a day
before a day before my homie just got
off the fest like a day before they took
how many homies was it
72 homies to the feds wow so the day
before i got an apartment in the valley
in sherman oaks and [ __ ] and basically
the valley is like what kept me out of
trouble in the mix and helped me
transition into the music and the
business cause had i stayed in la i
probably would have
like just been in trouble yeah people
don't like everyone comes you know and
it's crazy too cause like
you know i was just talking to d smoke
about this we're talking about how like
a lot of people come to la and they
think it's the place where you come get
your packs you come [ __ ] hit melrose
and then
you end up getting robbed right right it
was tricky it looked cute it looks
beautiful
but it's like everyone does the same
[ __ ] they come to la they rent a [ __ ]
some nice ass car
yeah they go to cookies yeah and then
they try to you know
yeah they you know and it's like
and then on the other end there's people
who move
everyone moves to the valley i feel like
everyone is in there in north hollywood
like like for sure they're over here but
this is the valley where is that it's
not la though right no it's not people
don't realize that like and i think
that's like like you could be
comfortable we're wearing a lot of [ __ ]
in the valley i'm not saying that you
know there's some
areas over here [ __ ] in north hollywood
that are sketched you know yeah they got
some kind of spots you know coima
obviously um van nuys but i feel like a
lot of people don't realize like
the level of comfort to just walk freely
wearing a certain [ __ ] is not the same
over on this side of the mountain right
this is actual l.a this is like not this
is the free world right here basically
the valley like it was like when i got
over here bro it was like a culture
shock you know what i'm saying like
i always stayed like on the outskirts of
the city but my whole life always been
you know something centered in the hood
spots uh whatever is going on whatever
we doing like
so when i came here it was like damn
this [ __ ] is smooth you know i mean i
had the time to like really just figure
myself out and figure my thing out but
you know la for [ __ ] that don't
know like la is basically when you cross
i ain't even gonna say olympic pico
south of pico
that's la you know what i mean
that's what like north of pico like
that's not really
not that's like it's nice male roles
don't even count as la that's like it's
west hollywood
at the moment are you still
living in l.a or are you in the valley
now uh
i got splashed in both
i got a spot in the valley in a spot in
l.a
i was going to say like well not in la
like i got a spot in [ __ ] west
hollywood right right right yeah west
hollywood's hot right now yeah
everybody getting robbed over there
you see the video of the guy you see the
video in the guy in the lamellae ball
jersey and they tried to run up on him
and he was and he served him oh i was
like yo
bro it's it's wow because i feel like um
like that that that influx of money that
influx of cash in the ghetto like it was
like i wasn't around when crack came out
but i heard stories i'm thinking maybe
this was similar like everybody had a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
eighty thousand everyone was hitting
legs
everybody
discovered melrose and now the money is
gone it's like all right we over here
yeah you know it's crazy during the
pandemic like you said like
that edd money was that ppp [ __ ] was
booming that [ __ ] was awesome man i hear
a lot of people talking [ __ ] and talking
down on people that did it and but it's
like bro if a [ __ ] was broke you'll be
talking down on them too oh you broke
ass [ __ ] ooh i'm happy eddie i'll be
hearing [ __ ] saying [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
like that but it's like bro like
what is [ __ ] to do he ain't
selling crack to your mama i can't wait
to see like in like 10 15 20 years like
the documentary about the ppp edd [ __ ]
it's gonna be crazy it's like an era
like
everyone was riding crazy everyone got
ice
right there's people like i know for a
fact where like dead ass broke and then
like 90 days fall out i'm like what the
[ __ ] you're driving a [ __ ] bentley
what happened like no
possibly
everything was you got to think about it
the world was froze
or anything i was tempted to you know i
had friends who were like bro you got a
llc
yo i'm telling you hey look you could
get like 100k and i'm like but i don't
but
i'm good dog
look so look that's crazy you say that i
got like four llc's right well i got a
little more than that now but at the
time i had four llc's and um
like i signed up for one right and got
approved for 90g i didn't even take it
though i'm like man i don't even really
need that [ __ ] and then i read the
stipulations all my [ __ ] legit mm-hmm
i'm like man i'm not about to be
checking in and nobody for no [ __ ] 90
gs like [ __ ] yeah it was tempting though
i wanted to but
because i just i opened this i just
opened the studio in february of 2020
and then the pandemic hit
i mean our ship was booming because all
the studios closed at least the major
studios closed yeah but we never closed
i was like i don't give a [ __ ] i just
opened this [ __ ] i invested a lot of my
own money into this place
we don't have a storefront people don't
music not stopping yeah so we thrived in
the pandemic but
i was it was definitely um
when it's that much money and is that
easy to get
it's hard to say no to which is why i
understand why a lot of people did but
like he said i think
i mean a lot of people going to jail now
right
a lot of people go in the gym right and
then i thought about it too like all
right i'll do one of these
like i'm
[ __ ] that bro like yeah you were smart
man i don't want a [ __ ] another car
note i already got like four of them
[ __ ] that's basically what that
would have been you know what i'm saying
like yo just get a new whip yeah you say
you you have a car's like your weakness
what what what what is like
your prized possession vehicle that you
have um right now probably the vet the
c8 is it is that the new one yeah it's
the same one freddie gibbs probably has
it yeah yeah he's got an orange he's got
the orange one yeah yours is blue
obviously yeah that makes sense
yeah that thing is like uh the new
corvette cause like a corvette went from
like being like you could get like a
fire one for like seventy five thousand
and new joints are like north of a
hundred and yeah it's marked up they're
fire though yeah it's like you're
driving a [ __ ] lambo it feels like
yes it's definitely a fun car but um
i'm already thinking about a couple
other vehicles that i want in in the um
next few months i'm i'm like holding
back from
i'll be spending too much money man i
mean cars are not the most wise
investment yeah
yeah so i'm holding back but i i want to
get a uh
i've been thinking about getting the
maybach the new maybach
i've seen him yeah the 21 maybach and
like m8 i'm saying oh yeah you're crazy
and then be my next gonna be my two
vehicles [ __ ] around just go buy a house
in santa clarita and rent it out to
someone that's much better what place to
put your buddy
right so that's that's what i said i
said i gotta at least get like this in
2022 i got to get at least like two
properties before i
do any like income property though yeah
warehouse i need a compound
because i rent all these houses and
recording i need to get a compound and
bro get a studio
get a you should just get one spot where
you have your studio you buy all your
machinery to make your own [ __ ] exactly
cut out the middle man man
and then and then
once you make all that money back then
go get the maybach yeah yeah you don't
need a maybach man that's just a i feel
like i do i know you do but you don't
all right
i've been having this conversation with
my wife all the time but i'm like listen
our cars are paid off we're good like
this one of these [ __ ] stops working
we're good right right right the only
car i'm going to [ __ ] off is when uh the
tesla truck the cyber truck when the
cyber truck look crazy that will be the
stupid purchase i make that cyber truck
is crazy but like bro it's about 30 cars
i want bro i got a problem yeah it
sounds like it
so i need to i need to drop a few more
projects and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying i'm gonna say like um
when you drop music now like
is the
first of all have you noticed like a
difference in the
the like the money you make
versus being independent versus you know
because how many projects did you drop
on rock nation was it two uh two yeah
and then you just dropped something and
i had about [ __ ] i recorded so much
bro were you able to keep those songs
objects
i mean i i got them but they sound like
from that time you know yeah i hear you
so it's like you know what though that's
uh something that artists do a lot is
that they'll have songs that are old to
them but are still [ __ ] fire yeah
yeah i probably need somebody to come
through and listen to that [ __ ] like
this yeah that [ __ ] happens all the time
like i like i like here like i remember
ty dolla sign played me his album like
two years ago it was like the greatest
[ __ ] i ever [ __ ] heard
and he didn't put it out for like a year
and a half and then it came out and it
was still good because he's thai
but i was like
i hit him i was like bro
what happened to that like the album you
played me with when you were grammy
yeah i'm in that [ __ ] man i'm like bro
that wouldn't it be like that once you
when you in there listening to it so
much for sure critique and [ __ ] and you
know it get like that shake your own
[ __ ] gets played out to you before the
world even hears it for sure yeah for
sure you record a lot now like are you
often hell yeah
hell yeah i keep so i keep a studio some
speakers and interface everywhere i'm at
at my house
at the studio house right uh
anywhere i got a studio on oceanside and
[ __ ] hey what up man we got to interrupt
the interview real quick to tell you
about our family at odd socks now when i
be riding for odd socks so hard man it's
because i really love the product they
got the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world i got a pair of odd socks
basics on right now go get those they
got the socks wwe joints you know i'm
saying shout out to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxoficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksoficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview um oceanside yeah oh nice
oceanside's fire yeah yeah so what
brought you over there
uh somebody i'll do business with um
yeah one of my business points there's a
vibe over there yeah oceanside is uh
it's like i've only i've only got an in
and out burger there but my sister wants
it in and out as soon as you pull up in
that welcome to osha's side then it's in
and out yeah
it's just like uh
where i stop and get food on my way to
go dj at flux in san diego it's like
it's a dope little beach city i heard it
used to be slummy and [ __ ] now it's nice
you know i mean but military city yeah
so the company the company that i'm with
that uh um partners in urban water
we basically got water in all the hotels
and it's a water company yeah wow that's
big i got to get you some water and [ __ ]
please some cases come through not
essential yeah we got we got much better
water than that right there it's called
urban water company yeah yeah so what's
the
ud well like what's the
everyone has a like what's special about
your water the ph levels the um or is it
just good water i mean i don't know it's
like there's water snobs so we got
spring water alkaline water uh cbd water
what a cbd water is like just for us
basically
yo there's some uh [ __ ] thc water
that i saw at the dispensary and i was
like who the [ __ ] is stupid enough to
drink a [ __ ]
highest [ __ ] bro again you can't you
can't get rid of that high right what do
you mean
or you drink it let me tell you a story
about an edible bro to save my life like
if i didn't eat this edible bro we
wouldn't be sitting here having this
interview it wouldn't be no g perico
nothing so
uh i could talk about it this is [ __ ]
12 years okay right
so we was uh
about to go hit a lick basically okay
and i'm not a robber or a jacker or any
of that [ __ ] i'm like a hustler player
pimp i'm saying gangster like
that's my thing you know what i'm saying
i know how to hustle it up but uh
so i was already out of my lane you know
what i mean but at the time like i was
down
you know i mean just took a loss and
[ __ ] so uh we go scope the [ __ ] out and
[ __ ] and it's like a dispensary before
they was popping up everywhere so every
dispensary that was
around that time was booming so we go in
and check it out
and um dude give me a [ __ ] uh
a peanut butter like oatmeal type cookie
that's an edible though right
and um we hadn't stopped and got nothing
to eat we just been on one all day so
i'm hungry as [ __ ] i knocked the cookie
back it was the whole thing the whole
cookie knocked the whole cookie back
right
by the time we get back to the hood i'm
tweaking i can't sit still
i'm like i'm thinking too much i'm
looking at everybody my mouth white and
[ __ ] i'm like [ __ ] i'm tripping right
so i tried to lay down we finally got
food i couldn't even eat
nigga's like gee you trick you acting
weird bro i'm like i know this [ __ ]
edible so long story short they leave
out the dog go to hit the lick i ain't
seen them [ __ ] since then oh and this
was about 12 years ago
i ain't seen them [ __ ] since
i ain't heard from him or nothing
wow yeah i mean something edible who
knows what happened yeah who knows what
happened to you the edible saved me man
damn straight up yup
uh i had a time where i had an edible
that i was only supposed to have like an
eighth of but i did the same thing yeah
it was so fire
and i ate the whole [ __ ] edible it
was tweaking bro i was hallucinating
i was uh
i was a it was it was like i was like
going to a concert and i'm supposed to
interview
both the artists of the concept
so i eat the edible
and um
the first uh it was a yellow wolf and
ritz concert so ritz is one of my close
homies and um so i eat the edible i
don't feel nothing right so i'm on the
bus i do the interview whatever
i'm like man i ain't adam i don't feel
[ __ ] bro i'm chilling you know what i'm
saying she's like cool i'm about to go
on stage so we go out we're going to the
show and as soon as this fool goes on
stage
kicked in bro like i couldn't move my
legs bro my legs felt like i'm like with
my boy and i'm like bro i can't walk my
legs feel like they're planted into the
ground
and then every everyone in the in the
concert
i could hear everyone's conversation
like i could like
it's probably a thousand people at this
show i can look across the room
and like hone in on someone having a
conversation at the bar
in the middle of a concert happening and
hear exactly what the [ __ ] they're
saying like i had sex superpowers type
[ __ ] yo
then i look up on stage
ritz is performing and next to him
there's uh animated garfield the cat
like a statue with uh
slot machine eyes going through like
with dollar signs in his eyes and out
bro
i start freaking the [ __ ] out and then
like everything that could have happened
that made my life like like if i like if
you were tripping all the weird [ __ ]
that could have actually happened in
front of you that night actually
happened like some native american dude
like walked up on me started freaking
out like asking me for my photo and
started telling me like about his tribe
and [ __ ] and this dude was like native
like [ __ ]
had all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] on his
head and i was like
i didn't think he was real
so i was telling my boy i'm like
do you see this in front of the guy i'm
like do you see this [ __ ] right
in front of me
the guy's like i hello i'm right here
and i'm like are you real
bro it was
i was puking it was never again
yeah that was um the last time i i did i
i've done edibles in like very small
doses but like that night and then there
was a night me and freddie did uh we
were in texas
and i did shrooms and an edible and
heated shrooms
and i thought i thought they were gonna
i thought
[ __ ] though no no for sure uh yeah i got
some shrooms here if you need them but
uh but no i did a i did shrooms and an
edible
we were uh
uh freddie gibbs went out there to do
joe rogan in austin so i went with him
and um
we went to a comedy show
and i was like you know what joe rogan's
coming i started doing shrooms because
of joe rogan i was like fred let's eat
some [ __ ] shrooms so we [ __ ] each
take like a we eat a lot of [ __ ]
shrooms but i had also eaten a lot of
edibles like i was just on some [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was out of town i was drinking i
was eating that party up bro
the worst it was like the most paranoid
freaked out night of my life bro we're
in this [ __ ] bar on sixth and i
thought that these dudes were gonna kill
fred i was like he he said some [ __ ] in
my ear like hey
and this all happened yo watch the
[ __ ] over there man brad is a
[ __ ] wild man bro and you know when
fred when he's drunk he's a wild man
he's drunk and on shrooms and so he's
like yo i'm gonna go peep the back door
of this bar make sure we got an exit
route and i'm like
so he's telling me that there's some
dudes like i ain't eyeing them right and
we're in texas i don't know nobody in
[ __ ] texas and all i could think of
was [ __ ]
we're gonna die like pop some hook died
we're gonna die like bob smoke died and
i'm gonna be with this [ __ ] i
might die too
bro
i'm like
losing my [ __ ] butt and i'm like
brian brian moses is our homie he's a
comedian i'm like bro did he just tell
me to look out and this guy's not doing
[ __ ] i'm supposed to be like his muscle
i'm like it's me and him and a girl yeah
and i'm like so it's on me to like
i'm [ __ ] tripping balls how am i
supposed to help in this if we get into
some [ __ ] i i'm in of no use here
it was it was a terrible night but yeah
edibles for me after that night i'm good
shrooms are amazing edibles stroms is
the [ __ ] you you [ __ ] with shrooms yeah
well i took too many shrooms one day
though i took too many shrimp in the
shower right
and i said i'm gonna i'm gonna stop
taking them bro cause i see how people
get spacey off of that [ __ ] yeah right
i'm in the shower and i got the face
towel in my hand and i looked down at it
and i was like man people treat me just
like this face towel
you know what i'm saying just use me and
throw me on it yeah i'm saying i'm like
wait hold up bro i'm [ __ ] tripping
yeah nah you know shrooms uh
they changed i mean people like if you
if you do that have you heard of doing a
hero's dose heroes though how much is
that
it's supposed to be at least the eighth
but i think it's two-eighths uh yeah
i've done hero though yeah if that's
what that is
i think it's two eighths that's a lot
and it's supposed to be like um
like the changing your life amount of
shrooms like you do it and you just like
work through all the problems in your
life yeah like it's yeah it make you
like it kind of make you a little too
calm
sometimes for me like i don't like being
that kind
like i'm what got you in my mind what
got you into doing shrooms because most
rappers are very uh they think it's like
meth like if i bring up like hey you do
shrooms a lot of rappers like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you bruh
i'm like bro it's not i didn't ask if
you smoke crack so i walked in uh i
walked in the studio one night well i
had been seeing it around and [ __ ] i
walk in the studio one night with my
partners and [ __ ] big big dudes too
and um everybody in there got sunglasses
on and [ __ ] right and i'm like
damn what's going on in this
[ __ ] right and i'm used to being
around like i grew up on the east side
right i'm used to [ __ ] being on
coke all the whole [ __ ] so i'm like yeah
maybe everybody up in here on blow or
something right
and um
like somebody said something and
everybody just started laughing and it
just turned in it was like super quiet i
guess people was quiet because i walked
in and i'm like the
sober guy you're not on their level yeah
and then they said something everybody
started laughing and they like yeah we
on shrooms
so i took a little piece
and i didn't feel i was scared though
took like a super small piece didn't
feel anything so like as much progressed
and [ __ ] like i'll be taking more and
more and then that last time i took so
much like i was [ __ ] tripping it was
awesome though but i don't think i could
be that cool have you uh heard of dmt
no
so dmt is like
that's
the closest
thing to looking like smoking crack but
it's so dmt is
it's a molecule that your brain produces
when you're born and when you're dead
so when you die dmt gets released
when you when you're born it gets
released
so
there's a frog
that sweats dmt that's based in the uh
in arizona in the desert right right so
they take it off a frog
so
and then they actually they obviously uh
in uh the amazon the frogs there as well
um
but you smoke dmt you have to free base
it though so you literally ha you
literally have to smoke it come out
you literally have to smoke it from a
crack pipe
you know obviously there's no crack
but
it is
like uh you smoke dmt you hit the you
hit the pipe and then you're just you're
just gone for 15 minutes in another
planet
yeah and people say that like
it expands your mind to like realize
like how
small in the world you are like it opens
like a portal to like
it's
[ __ ] up because it's like
once you certain people get too smart
and then they just like hear like it's
their purpose in life and things that
they need to do just
like i feel like
i mean if you've done a lot of shrooms
you might be down for dmt though yeah
right in the right setting i'm kind of
like
not like super heavy on shrooms like i
didn't try them a couple times did a lot
one time and was like yeah i'm kind of
cool but
like i don't uh
bro i feel like that [ __ ] just i like
grew up around drug addicts i'm from the
ghetto you know what i'm saying
everybody is a [ __ ] addict to
something alcohol for sure for sure coke
um
weed is like wrecked weed is nothing
actually i feel like weed and shrooms
are the same as far as like
so it's like
bro certain drugs that take you
somewhere and open your mind up and
bring you somewhere i feel like it kind
of like steals it's still your passion
for whatever you trying to do like you
just fine with existing however that's
just me from the outside looking in at
certain people that i know
like that just found that special place
in the world like and just happy and
cool and
[ __ ] that
i still need my
motivation yeah i'm tripping like [ __ ]
this we got to get this done and you
know what i mean i need that um
talk about your relationship with greedo
because you obviously you know
three greedo's got
12 000 songs that no one's heard yet
free my boy greedo so me and greedo got
a whole project together right so when
greedo was uh
because you know greedo been out for a
long time yeah he's been doing this
thing for a long time he's been out for
a long time but when he started blowing
up as uh greedo
and like [ __ ] was owning you
know what i mean uh
i remember he was talking that [ __ ] yeah
i just did 12 songs today oh i did 20
songs today so i'm like the next time we
get in the studio like i'm competitive
you know what i'm saying like that's how
the g worthy project came about but
we'll talk about that but like when we
get in the studio i'm like man this
[ __ ] not about to run circles
around me in here you know what i'm
saying so every time a beat came on
i'm trying to rush in the booth because
he just
he hear the beat and he just casually
walks in the booth
and comes out in five minutes
with the [ __ ] done you know what i'm
saying
so when they when it when everything
come on i'm trying to i'm rushing in
there you know what i mean and we uh at
the end of the night we ended up with a
project one of the songs came out on uh
uh first
a good job first yeah fkr first shot he
dropped he dropped one of the songs that
we did that night
and um
and we still probably got about like 15
songs in my computer and [ __ ]
um
probably dropped some more of that [ __ ]
but that's basically what that was so
his creative process is have you ever
seen anyone record that fast because i
mean from what
it's tight no tk was telling me like the
amount of songs he has um
it's insane yeah like it's almost like
you don't believe it until you see like
damn i
like this guy's drops music like he's a
[ __ ] machine i think he just learned
how to just have a conversation not
like he just learned how to be like one
with the music if that makes sense like
because
like he bro he's i know for sure he's
not thinking hard about nothing the beat
come on
he talking [ __ ] yeah
walk in and then walk back out like you
know i'm saying the only time i seen him
like
like pressure and that ain't even
pressure was like when he pressing the
engineer like give my [ __ ] sounding
right
like what i'm saying but outside of that
he like that nigga's like water like he
just wouldn't you uh the
joint project that you're sitting on is
there any sort of idea when that's gonna
um we've been talking about it she's on
your your album what couple times right
yeah he on there um he called me one day
and [ __ ]
and um
and he like man put out some of that
[ __ ] and i thought about it so i took uh
jay nori actually took a piece from um
one of the joints and uh mixed it into
too sexy and um
[Music]
and uh we just had a conversation and
[ __ ] we was talking i'm like i'm gonna
record it you know what i'm saying and
we just talking [ __ ]
and i chopped pieces from the
conversation and put them inserts on
certain songs and [ __ ] how's he doing uh
you know how's his spirit
bro he [ __ ] he better than me put it
like that i'm not stressing
he popping that [ __ ] he talking like he
out on the streets you know what i'm
saying so
um i know when he get out he's not gonna
have a problem getting straight back
into it like
he like a special one-of-a-kind type
[ __ ] like i ain't never seen
nobody like him you know what i mean
yeah i thought one of the doper moments
that i saw
kind of the original verses was him and
rj and nobody got hurt at the novo yeah
i was fired that was fire
that was super fire and he walked my
game up about a lot of [ __ ] too like
like what
just basically like uh
just me being like back to like being a
[ __ ] gangbanger from the streets like
sometimes
the uh
the mentality of that carry over into
this but this ain't that and that ain't
this you know what i'm saying so like
being able to uh
differentiate uh
the two you know what i'm saying
is is real difficult that's why you
don't see
a lot of artists like myself or with the
background like myself cracking or on
the scene
it's because they let the other [ __ ]
bleed into this [ __ ] and they're
and it took a while for me to understand
that
bro this is entertainment all these
[ __ ] doing this [ __ ] these [ __ ]
cripping extra hard and blending extra
hard
it's a costume it's for the you know
what i'm saying so
like
and me coming from the real life
and like
shedding blood for this [ __ ] sweat tears
years of my life you know what i'm
saying actually putting in work [ __ ] and
like living it it's like
you know that part of me is hard to turn
that part of me off and accept
they're separate yeah except the
entertainment aspect of it like
[ __ ] acting super hard and like
they this and that you know what i'm
saying so
that's why a lot of uh
like real ones not in the mix you know
what i'm saying so i just been learning
how to accept it you know what i'm
saying and um
you know that was probably hard like
because you're very difficult you get
into
hip-hop world and like you said there's
a lot of perceived
gangsters involved yeah but
it's separate right it's like look
there's the entertainment industry
and then there's the other [ __ ] and it's
hard to mix both and make it because
i mean really you're more of a target
when you become a public figure you know
what i mean for sure you're more of like
you know look i mean [ __ ] all the rico
[ __ ] that's happening all the [ __ ]
bro that [ __ ] is so that [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] spooky bro oh it's insane they
could just snatch you up and say that
you doing some if they feel like it say
you doing some criminal [ __ ] like who
really what successful artist or
successful businessman
really has time to run a functioning
street gang or a street activity like
now if you got ties to this [ __ ] you
can't help that like and then nine times
out of ten you're not gonna turn your
back on your people so yo
like
my presence my presence in the street
life right now with my homies and [ __ ]
is just for sheer motivation and like
bro we need to be doing this this and
this [ __ ] that it's
no life into the [ __ ] that's been going
on for i just told my homie the other
day bro like one of my young homies like
bro you're not
bro you're not going to be special or do
anything different or
you're not going to be
who you want to be
doing the same [ __ ] that's been going on
in the hood for the last 50 years you
know what i'm saying like bro we got
homies from since 60s 70s that kill
[ __ ] and do the crazy [ __ ] and go to
jail forever like what makes you think
that you're gonna stand out and be
special doing the same exact [ __ ] and we
know the outcome bro yeah you already
seen this movie play out there's people
who did this for you just to show you
like yeah yeah bro it's decades of
seeing it though bro we got hundreds of
homies
maybe a thousand homies in jail with
life and like that wish they wouldn't
did this [ __ ] so it's like
bro and that's why
that's why my transition into this [ __ ]
like sometimes it's difficult but when i
look at that it's like all right i could
be doing this and be stuck in and out of
prison who wants to do that who gives a
[ __ ] about that you know what i'm saying
it's like all right do something
different what can i bring different to
the hood so my presence is
bringing that different [ __ ] and making
it cool like all right let's do music
um let's do clothes do all right you uh
water you don't wrap or yeah water you
know rap all right um
you don't even want to be in the
entertainment [ __ ] okay it's real estate
it's other business [ __ ] like and it's
fine you still a homie you still cool
like [ __ ] with [ __ ] talking about you
know what i'm saying you know what it is
man i think there's a lot of it is
is feeling like you
like you
everyone is guilty of
trying to fit in trying to fit in and
being and feel like they're included
and i had to i had a
difficult time with that [ __ ] when i
came into this because
you know naturally i'm in the forefront
of all the ignorant [ __ ]
and then when i transition over now i'm
missing it and i'm not there and then
it's people saying slick [ __ ] when i
ain't around like
that [ __ ] was very difficult
transitioning over and being able to
accept it but it's like once you get
over into the transition it's all worth
it because
[ __ ] gonna follow success and
want to be like success regardless you
know what i'm saying was it hard also to
ignore when you hear someone saying some
wild [ __ ] very [ __ ] difficult because
you got a lot to lose while the
[ __ ] probably talking crazy
ain't got [ __ ] to lose bro very
difficult and i had to realize that like
all right my contribution to the area
like
there's always been one million from the
jump you know what i'm saying like i
keep spots for homies to go to on [ __ ]
for people to go to so nine times out of
ten somebody lending a negative opinion
about me
ain't even
had any contribution to the area in a
positive or a negative way like in any
type of way that makes a difference
anyway but yeah that [ __ ] was like super
difficult for me to uh
i hear all that [ __ ] you know i'm saying
and it at first it was super difficult
to turn the other cheek because i'm used
to the action like [ __ ] what's
happening but
bro i worked entirely too hard and you
got a lot more to lose man and it's and
it's not only me
yeah it's like a lot of people
that's working with me and he put me in
these [ __ ] hours with me you know
what i'm saying and other people that
believe in me and might be invested and
they got families and so it's bigger
than me at this point so for me to go
backwards and do some [ __ ] [ __ ] not
only like [ __ ] letting people down i'm
i'm [ __ ] people [ __ ] up you know what
i'm saying and you know people could be
anywhere it's a big world like there's
so many different ways to make money and
like the music game is like worse than
the [ __ ] lotto you'll win a lotto
before you [ __ ] be big and this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so
you know i think about that too that's
some real [ __ ]
there's so many rappers i don't know i
think in spotify there's like
i forget how many songs a week it
uploaded it's something it's something
ridiculous close to them it's a few
hundred thousand it's a lot yeah and you
gotta think like okay
and being able to cut through that like
to even be in the top couple hundred
people
or the top thousand people like that's
[ __ ] huge yeah that's that shit's
it's almost impossible right yeah
um talk about the g worthy [ __ ] g worthy
oh yeah so the g worthy that was another
night uh
that was crazy so when i walked in we
walked in the studio
um
and i was like i had like a cold so i
got nyquil
trying to like open my [ __ ] up you know
i mean and as soon as i walk in this was
the first night i met cardo we've been
talking on the phone and [ __ ] you know
cardo
he up on everything new that's
up-and-coming anything that's a thing
like he just got some sense on how to
like oh yeah that's
so he he up on everything new so this
was my first time in it just meeting
them as soon as we walk in jokes bagging
right feel like we've been knowing each
other for years bros you know i mean and
um
[Music]
jay worthy had already started on a song
so the competitiveness in me woke up
inside i'm hot oh this [ __ ]
what all right so now it's like we
basically in my mind i didn't say it out
loud i don't know what he was thinking
but every time something come on
i'm trying to get on there first that's
why sometimes you hear him first
sometimes you hear me first that's like
who right at that time i was still
writing my raps
and then while we doing this cardo
um polyester diamond ortiz they over
there making the beats so we did all
that [ __ ] in one night one night then
the next the next day we did the album
cover you know what i'm saying wow so
this was like a one night process you
know what i mean and we was just all in
there just we joking having a good time
but
just the aggressive competitive
spirit was also there and that [ __ ] was
to this day that's like some of my top
streaming [ __ ] that's where everybody
you know
yeah
had a great run just
doing full projects with people and yeah
you know running it up larry yeah he
just dropped something larry june right
last friday yeah carter was amazing man
he just he got it's something about him
man yeah cardo uh
you know i think he's under appreciated
too we're talking about the best
producers yeah
cardo definitely up there he's up there
for sure um who are you a fan of right
now in la that's that you're maybe not
you know did you just
not anybody who's maybe under you but
just someone who you just can
acknowledge like man i really [ __ ] with
their [ __ ] i mean i'm i'm really i'm
enjoying the whole l.a scene right now
like
i love what uh
i love what rumble like rambles fire
like rumble like rumble like definitely
like like draco came and changed the
game you know what i'm saying and then i
feel like
uh rumble was taking it to like adding
his twist on it and i'm saying it got
everybody rapping like him like
love what rambo doing i love what draco
doing i love what uh ruchi and shike
doing i love what uh
man it's so many people like right now
on the come up that's that's out here
fire oh geezy killing
you know what i mean um
i hate starting to name names because i
leave someone out yeah yeah i mean but
uh
like i'm just i'm really a fan of the
whole city you know what i'm saying like
i'm for the just l.a [ __ ] like oh i'm
like a die-hard l.a [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying yeah it's crazy like draco
like the output he has is also insane
yeah i don't even know how many he got
out last year
we interviewed him like a week after i
didn't even think he went off for a year
yet no he hasn't and he's put out
six albums it's [ __ ] insane it's like
jesus man the guys
that's a lot i hope him and we're gonna
have chike and ruchi up your neck i hope
they figure out their issues you know
because yeah i was like the first body
make more money that way hey for sure
um
what is next for you man
um
i got a lot of i got a few things up my
sleeve you know what i mean but uh more
music another project so
like with the everything that i've been
dropping i ain't even really spent no
money on marketing at all
so the top of the year we just going
crazy heavy marketing i'm opening up i'm
spending the budget you know what i mean
it's top of the year so we're just going
to finish off the year probably another
project or two i got something the
collab project besides the greeting do
you have any other any other artists you
want to try to collab with on yes
it's a few people that i'm working on
and working with you know i mean it's
going to be dope when we uh when we
announce it and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying so i mean next year i just want
to just level everything up and then
i've been shooting these short films and
[ __ ] so i got a couple of short films
that i'm about to drop oh fire yeah i
want to get into the acting i did a
couple movies uh
i did like two movies last year i did a
movie this year you know what i mean
like some actual real movies right i
mean are you getting like what what what
kind of roles is are you getting like
typecasted as like the gangster guy yeah
the uh the first [ __ ] i did was uh it
was typecast
and they had me being i kind of hated it
because it's like you got me playing the
la dude like i'm
a doc i'm like the epitome of l.a
gangster like right you don't got to
tell me what to say yeah like that's
what you do yeah yeah i'm gonna give you
the raw uncut [ __ ] but um like the last
movie that i did was uh
and i think it might turn into a tv
series so i'm gonna be a reoccurring
character even better yeah um [ __ ] um
vanessa del rio
which is like one of the first ethnic
porno stars ever like before her was
nothing but white girls and [ __ ] she
like afro latina
from out the 70s like
just doing like crazy porn i should do
some research so yeah i'm in her bio pic
and uh oh [ __ ] yeah oh that's fire yeah
i'm in our bio pic it's like some
pictures floating around the net they
promoting the movie where i got the afro
and the
bell bottoms and [ __ ] so that might be
uh that might that's the one that might
end up being a series yeah that's fire
yeah hey that's an interesting story
yeah so uh
you know i'm in there doing my thing you
know what i mean and uh
yeah i'm in the air doing my thing and
uh
and then the [ __ ] that i'm working on
like i got a couple movies this like
typecast and then i got some
you know that i want to expand on
because i really want to do this acting
[ __ ] bro like i mean yeah now we just
watched uh the d smoke video the other
day you were in it
that was the longest video i've seen in
a long time yeah yeah that was fun when
we we did that video too yeah everybody
was there you rj him i was like oh like
this is fire like yeah
what's your like relationship did you
have a relationship with these smoke
prior to him obviously getting the
notoriety from being on the show yeah so
d smoke uh actually boxed at broadway
boxing gym
and um
you know that's where my uh studio was
under there and then my first store
was also up under there so i met him
like years before he blew up and um i
didn't even know he was talented like or
sung or anything i just know he was a
boxer [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] up you know
what i'm saying
and um
[Music]
i remember he had a boxing match like
one day that i had a pop-up down there
and [ __ ] and he kicked somebody ass you
know what i mean and then i don't know
if they want us to say this yet but me
dee smoke and um david gross actually
own that building now oh congrats and um
in the boxing gym or spoiler alert i
hope they not man
yeah so we uh yeah we bought the
building so yeah yeah yeah and we um we
own uh broadway boxing so it came with a
business so now you and these smoker
business partners yup oh that's fire man
yep and the crazy thing um
like uh we were speaking on it like bro
like if the opportunity ever presented
itself i love to own that building he
liked me too and the opportunity
presented itself like 60 days later wow
and we in there you know i mean so uh a
building that means a lot to both of you
guys yeah super because i i changed my
whole life right there in that building
like from a hunt from the valley to
108th every day wow that's where i
transition into
all right out of having to do criminal
[ __ ] like all right and now i'm creating
opportunities for people in the area you
know what i mean congrats man that's
huge
but look you
know that's that's a nice investment
that's not a uh that's that's not a
maybach
it's a super dope investment so
and that's why i say i want to give me a
maybach now he's like yo i made a good
one now let me get this bad boy
back but yeah i'm definitely going uh
looking to grab other properties and
[ __ ] like i got a i got like a nice i
think this is the first time in my life
like i got a like serious future plan
and it's actually
like beyond possible but the numbers are
so big and crazy like it's like i'm in a
great position right now man
congratulations
uh looking forward to the new music yeah
and uh man thanks for pulling up man
thanks for having me